[Music]
earlier today newt gingrich announced
that he would drop out of the
presidential campaign next week so the
race is over for newt and that also
means the end of the line for our
incredible newt gingrich impersonator
world-renowned andy richter any Chum
Sean the Newt Gingrich impression come
on it's it's it's a wig and too big a
face is what it is all right there he is
[Applause]
fantastic
well we are now we're gonna swear saying
goodbye to Newt so I thought we'd send
Andy off with a look back at newts run
for the presidency
[Music]
goodbye Newt you fought hard and
outlasted many of your rivals will miss
your fiery passion
you're a creepy charm and yes even your
often terrifying sense of fun when
you're stacked with the money dried up
one person stayed by your side your
third loving life
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh it's a freeze frame we have a freeze
frame we got a hold it
later after the show we got a smoothie